no I don't I don't think so I think
there are too many clashes within each
of the civilizations to to talk about a
clash of Mozilla's ations to describe
them but it is true that that when when
fundamentalists or zealots or Orthodox
or ultra-orthodox people take over a
country then they're there they will
repress the moderates and the liberals
in their own camp and then we confront
them and that does that does look like
kind of us against them but we always
have to remember in those situations the
people who've been repressed all of the
liberal and secular Afghans for example
who who who survived the Taliban regime
but we didn't hear from them while the
Taliban were in power but they're there
and those should be our our allies and
since we all since we always have allies
in the other civilizations I think it's
a big mistake to try to try to describe
it as a kind of war of of unified
culture